Wie viel verdienst du beziehungsweise wie viel hat man dort pro stunde ungefähr verdient
mindestlohn oder ein bisschen mehr hey leute was geht ab und herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen video ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut ich hoffe jetzt auch gut das ist nämlich die karrubis heute dabei ich musste erst mal sagen
sehr professionell ich hatte eigentlich vor dass heute somit anstecken die kosten machen auf richtig professionell leider waren die irgendwie kaputt ging nicht richtig an
deswegen machen wir das mit meinem iphone also das ist heute das
Und zwar freue ich mich sehr dass du heute hier bist sie hat mir bei einzahlungen geschrieben die video idee von dem heutigen video kommt
eigentlich komplett von dir also ich fand sie gut und habe gesagt ey wenn der bock hast kommt nochmal vorbei und das hat sie gemacht
sie ist heute über fünf stunden aus niedersachsen her gefahren hier nach köln einfach nur mit mir dieses video zu drehen und machen heute so
ein interview weil sie gerne meine videos schaut und auch mal so das eine oder andere
mcdonald's video geguckt hat und gesagt hat du hast immer so viele fragen beantwortet ihr die allemal weil sie von
2018 bis 2019 bei mcdonald's selber gearbeitet hat und deswegen wie heute
Ich komme aus
Ok also ich habe bei instagram gestern gesagt bei dem slogan heisst alex wie konnte er gern mal vorbei schauen dass die leute mir fragen
stellen können
wegen der oder an dich und das haben sehr viele gemacht wir haben ultra viele fragen zusammen manche habe ich 20 30 mal gelesen also
20 30 leute hatten die gleiche frage und ich habe die 20 besten ausgewählt die stelle ich dir jetzt gleich und ich würde sagen wir
fangen direkt mal an
also wenn du irgendwas nicht beantworten willst dann sagt das kann ich verstehen weil du meinst ja dass du auf bestimmte dinge nicht eingehen kann
wenn man da ja so ein vertrag unterschreibt dass man keine betriebsgeheimnisse auffordern kann aber das ist ja überall sozusagen gar nicht schlimm und
ja also einfach sagen okay gibt es noch irgendwas zu sagen ich glaube nicht es kann ein sehr langes video werden also wirklich bei den
ganzen fragen deswegen vielleicht sollten wir das in zwei teile und ich habe ja schon gesagt den zweiten part machen wir dann eventuell im auto
das
ok also ich freue mich auf die ganzen antworten wirklich weil mich viele davon extrem
interessieren wir fangen ich fange einfach mal so kreuz und quer an mit der ersten frage
und zwar das wird sehr sehr oft gefragt weil das er auf you tube dieser trend selben trend ist
hast du mal live ein break von einem youtuber miterlebt also weißt du dass das sich halt irgendwie verarschen wollte an an diesem
schalter also wie ich schon gesagt habe ich wohl ab ende der welt allein also meine antwort ist ganz einfach neue also wir hatten doch
nirgendwo irgendein youtuber der sitze dachte soll jetzt endlich mal irgendwie
mitarbeitern ja gut also ich glaube dass es hier so in köln oder im ruhrgebiet
viel krasser ich kann ja auch den ein oder anderen er sowas öfter macht und der meinte der
stimmigen wurden fand weil er immer direkt erkannt wird und weggeschickt wird also hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert wenn das bei dir schon vorgekommen ist
aber es gibt ja immer so war
dorf bambus sage ich mal die auch sein so youtube machen wollen und dass man halt auch machen ich glaube dass in köln so was
einfach übliches war ich würde auch generell viel gefilmt und bei uns ist einfach
nichts also gut
zweite frage machen wir direkt am anfang ich weiß eigentlich schon die antwort aber das haben sehr viele gefragt
auch weil ich das schon mal thematisiert habe warum ist immer eure eismaschinen kaputt
beziehungsweise meistens abends gibt es ja kein eis mehr wird immer gesagt hier ist kaputt vorliegt also meistens liegt da
liegt es daran dass die eismaschine eben geputzt werden muss das wissen viele nicht aber bei uns ist das zum beispiel
so
dass oft entweder zum beispiel auch das als das nachgefüllt dann muss also die focus also die saucen die halt nicht mehr vorhanden sind wieder
schon kunde auch sonst kam der neu ist die müssen auch nachgefüllt werden und in der zeit oder plötzlich so ein dreister
10.000 bestellungen sind kann dann halt eben kein eis ausgegeben werden weil das erstmal nachgefüllt werden auswählen und alles ist das meistens oder nachts bei
uns ist das so dass halt um 23 uhr morgens dann hast du die ganzen leute plötzlich auf die spontane idee kommen sich nun milchshake
zu bestellen
die ganzen kids die kommen
Nicht nur
Klar das ist das war auch so eine frage also stelle ich hier gleich noch dass wir da dann kein eis mehr ausgeben können weil
dann ab 23 uhr morgens hat die maschine dann halt ausgestellt wird weil sie sich selber
und wie er sagt jedoch nicht so jung also liegt halt daran bei wenigerath räubern müssten weil die meisten ja die ist kaputt also
fast ihr auch ehrlich sagen ich warum die sagen die ist kaputt weil eigentlich also in unseren betrieb zu sagen wir immer das
Weil ich habe bis jetzt auch nie gehört so die wird gesäubert oder der magnolia die ist kaputt und dann denkt man sich halt immer
sowieso ist immer eure scheiße maschine kaputt das kann doch nicht sein aber gut also ich hab es gehört zwar die antwort darauf sehr interessant
das habe ich mich auch schon oft gefragt weil bei mir geht das klappt das irgendwie nie du darfst ja kein trinkgeld
annehmen dort ist es richtig ja dafür nicht also bei mcdonald's nicht weil das ist ja jetzt nicht so
was passiert jetzt hier mit meiner kamera stehen und kurzen kath obwohl jetzt geht's wieder also du darfst kein trinken
Oder
Ja gut ist halt so also wenn es vom chef so vorgegeben ist oder vom von der ganz obersten etage dann
kann man halt nichts machen eine frage die ich einfach mal mit reingenommen habe weil ich so dachte okay
ganz
interessant wenn jemand zu wenig geld mit hat hast du doch schon mal ein bisschen weniger verlangt wahrscheinlich geht das nicht mehr kannst du nicht
machen oder kann ich da nicht rausgeben also wenn dann jemand sagt ich habe noch 80 cent für den bürger dann sagst ja
gut dann gehört da ist die tür
ja ist ja auch logisch also ich meine weil du musst das ja am ende aus
das würde wenn die kassenabrechnung dann gemacht wird bis zu dann normal oder
kassenabrechnung dem sinne also so wie man es kennt das machen die chefs dann sag ich mal die abteilungs die
schichtführer die sagen dann wenn irgendwas mit der kasse nicht stimmt aber
also wir machen das sowieso schon gar nicht aber wieder vom trotzdem halten wert rausgeben weil
einfach ja das ist in so einem unternehmen durch auch
selbstverständlich weil weg jetzt laden sagen wo
keine ahnung wie viele umsätze gemacht werden und wenn dann jeder so unter dem wert an irgendwas kriegen würde weil er sagt er zu wenig
geld mit
natürlich also das ist einfach nur
wirtschaftlich
nicht tragbar sagen wir mal so eine frage die ich glaube das war die meistgestellte frage ist ja auch logisch weil darin dreht sich ja
vieles in unserer gesellschaft
ich weiß nicht ob du das sagen kannst wie viel verdienst du bzw wie viel hat man dort pro stunde ungefähr verdient
mindestlohn oder ein bisschen mehr ach so ich habe
die schule gemacht habe habe ich 150 euro
von der arbeitsweise ändert sich jetzt nichts
machen und wenn man dann halt vollzeit gibt es ja auch noch es gibt ja vollzeit die verdienen dann weißt du was die pro stunde
vor dem mindestlohn
ok also wahrscheinlich liegt schon nahe dass es mindestlohn ist
ok aber was mir auffällt es gibt ja schon immer leute also ihr habt ja es gibt ja leute die haben zum beispiel diese ganz
normalen standard sachen an und es gibt leute die haben dann irgendwie so einen anzug an oder so leicht enthemmt weißt du so ein blaues
fällt mir manchmal auch das sind dann die leiche oder
die schichtführer die haben dann meistens dieses mcdonald's
entlassen die sehen dann ein bisschen anders aus die haben dann auch so andere schuhe sogar also ja meistens alle so alle schwarze
extra geschichte der schule weil wenn es fertig ist oder so und man nicht ausnutzen
Und die verdienen aber auch mehr schon das weißt du aber nicht nee aber ich gehe davon aus weil das habe ich mich immer gefragt
inwiefern die sich von den anderen dort absetzen das war jetzt gerade auf fünf fragen wir sind schon bei neun minuten
also die zeit verfliegt immer schnell wenn man so ein video auf dann hoffe ich mal auch für dich
als nächstes kommen wir zu der zeit meist
gestellten frage ich paare die jetzt einfach mal am anfang raus weil wahrscheinlich sind das so auch die fragen die euch alle interessieren und zwar
wenn du dort arbeitet darfst du dir immer belohnt was umsonst nehmen oder darfst du dir alles nehmen was du willst oder nicht
Also
wir verdienen halt pro stunde mal so ein bestimmtes essensgeld und dann dürfen wir uns den wert den wir dann einen stunden gearbeitet haben
zum beispiel
Also wenn du jetzt mal angenommen pro stunde dann eines lohn von einem euro bekommt und 19 mitarbeiter das dürftest du für neun euro essen
Also merkt euch wenn ihr bei mcdonald's seit über den schränken stehen angebrochene getränke
ach so genau wenn du dann aber selber jetzt sagt er ich hab grad mega hunger ich tue ich weiß jetzt drei euro in die
runde und würde ihn gern drei duisburger essen dann darf das auch nur in der pause wahrscheinlich ist ja ist ja logisch
auch einfach irgendwas bezahlen
Nachdem es gerade nach dem jetzt fast unsere pizza hier verbrannt ist
habe ich mich wieder hingesetzt und wir kommen zur nächsten frage haben auch sehr viele
gestellt wäre ich gar nicht drauf gekommen gibt es eine festgelegte wartezeit bei der der kunde bei zu langem warten die bestellung kostenlos bekommt
nicht dass ich wüsste also ich weiß dass ab einer bestimmten zeit jeder weiß so nett war und gesagt
tut uns echt leid fürs warten dann haben wir meistens noch ein eis dazu gelegt oder so haben gefragt ob die vielleicht noch irgendwas wollen
also wenn ich zwei stunden auch meine bestellung gewalt habe hast du dann gesagt you here christoph
Also ich habe in unserem betrieb jetzt mitbekommen
Also also als die gäste hatten wahrscheinlich auch mal
was war so das schlimmste erlebnis was sie mit einem gast hat ist oder kann sich daran noch erinnern
das ist schwierig also es gibt oft besoffene leute die eben teils sehr
aggressiv reagieren auf andere betrunkene gäste zb und dann
eskaliert das war ich glaube einer zum beispiel hat sich irgendwie mal
von mcdonald's weitergegeben oder so mag dann die ganze zeit auf dem boden also kann man nicht raus
und dann muss das geklärt werden also ich weiß nicht so nah gut also aber klar das hat man
wenn man irgendwo ein restaurant führt was nach 10 oder nach nur auf hat wo leute dann auch alkohol trinken oder mehr leute alkohol trinken
ich glaube da bleibt das nicht aus wie bist du dazu gekommen dass du gesagt hast
ich hätte es mal bei mcdonald's zu arbeiten weil du hast ja hast mir eben erzählt dein abitur auch gemacht nebenbei also mein fachabi
ich habe mich dazu entschieden weil also freunde von mir haben dann schon gearbeitet
man kann halt als schüler als student muss ich sagen echt gut geld verdienen also es geht auch recht schnell also ich würde es auch
ehrlich gesagt den leuten empfehlen also wenn die jetzt so
nebenjob suchen oder so schülerjobs also wirklich den echten vielen snacks zu gehen
ich hatte das glück dass ich echt nette leute hatte also wir haben uns im team mega gut
verstanden hat auch spaß gemacht also gleich war nicht korrekt drauf und wenn ich immer so witze reißen zwischendurch weiß ich seit
schüler job finde ich eignet sich das echt gut aber ich weiß nicht ob ich das dann halt so
hauptberuflich machen würde sage ich mal weiß dann doch schon manchmal echt stressig ist
Das haben auch viele gefragt ob manchmal halt halt stressig ist oder wenn du dann halt an der kasse arbeitet oder am 3
und dann vielleicht auch noch mal wechseln muss oder so und dann viele leute kommen und dann auch noch oben ob sie wieder gesagt hast
ist wahrscheinlich schon stressig war nicht so
stressig kann es auf jeden fall seien vor allem wie man dann im drive alles voll hat und in der lawi alles voll hat und
du musst also meistens arbeiten bei magna ist jetzt nicht so viele leute wie alle davon aus- gehen also es werden eigentlich mehr arbeitskräfte
benötigt sag ich jetzt mal und wenn dann so die leute mit dem tempo nicht hinterher kommen weil
wir hatten mal einen fall glaube ich da standen bis zur einfahrt bis zum parkplatz von mcdonalds
aller autos am treff und frage mich wer sich dann noch extra hinten dran stellt mit dem auto nur um auf 1 1 zu warten
so gut und vielleicht um das video jetzt
abzuschließen weil wir hatten gerade die
sensationelle idee dass wir doch einen zweiten partner machen wo wir dann im auto die anderen fragen klären und mal bei mcdonald's
vorbeifahren du kannst ja doch noch mal gucken wie diese ob sie das
Das kommt dann halt die tage online vielleicht schon morgen je nachdem
es kommt natürlich auch wir haben ja eben schon mal darüber gesprochen so was für jene angeht weil das wollen natürlich auch wenn es viele
wissen wie ist die qualität
und wie werden die bürger dort zubereitet ist das
hygienisch gesehen gut oder hast du da auch schlechte erfahrungen mit gemacht kann es ja einfach mal deine erfahrung sagen
also ich habe jetzt nichts gesehen was mich erschrecken sagen ich mache also ich weiß natürlich nicht wie das in anderen
filialen ist ich kann das jetzt
weil man muss ja dazu auch sagen dass viele privat geführt werden und ist ja eigentlich wie dann auch einen allein schönes restaurant
manche führen dass hygienisch gesehen besser manche schlechter
dass es wird ja nicht alles vom selben geführt deswegen wenn da einer darauf achtet ist es denke ich mal
hygienisch gut oder nicht
In der lobby scart ausgang mal bitte nochmal durch die lobby oder so also es wird schon wird schon drauf geachtet
zb das sehen auch oft die kunden wenn zum beispiel jemand einer friteuse steht und eben einmal die chance für runter fällt kann es ja
nicht ja das wäre ja das würde ja gar nicht gehen wir auch für das wasser in der friteuse gewechselt da dieses öl dass
Das wurde auch oft gefragt ist mir gerade eingefallen
alles klar dann würde ich sagen haben wir schon einen langen ersten part gedreht das geht jetzt bestimmt schon an die 20 minuten deswegen
erstmal danke dass du mitgemacht hast und wir schwingen uns jetzt gleich ins auto und dann bin ich mal gespannt
wie der zweite part wird bestimmt noch lustiger
deswegen schaut euch das sehr gerne die tage an lassen doch nach oben da und was ich an dieser stelle auch noch sagen möchte
da habe ich die kamera auf diese idee gebracht hat habe ich so gedacht vielleicht kann es auch mal ein interview führen mit im
lieferando fahrer oder mit einem burger king mitarbeiter oder einem schwindler ist mir auch noch einen gefallen
das heißt dass richtet sich jetzt an euch wenn ihr
in diesem berufsfeld tätig seit und bock habt dass man mit mir zu machen ich stelle keine schlimmen fragen oder so nur das was sie
selber wollt dann schreibt mir gerne über instagram alex wie und bei cover könnte auch bei insidern vorbeischauen möchte
dann schreibe ich mal in die video beschreibung wirklich vielen dank für die lange zugfahrt und wir drehen jetzt noch weiter das war's schöne grüße
daumen nach oben und ciao